it was really important to me to do well
on my gmat after completing an
undergraduate degree in business i
wanted to complete a finance master at
the london school of economics and then
after some years working at mckinsey i
wanted to do an mba at insert and for
both of these programs i need a gmat and
i needed a good gmat a good score i
really needed to get this right and with
only three weeks of preparation i scored
above 700 on my first and only sitting
of the gmat exam hi there my name is
heinrich and welcome to my channel firm
learning if you are a first time viewer
of this channel on this channel i try to
help you to become successful in the
first years of your career i draw from
my experience having worked at mckinsey
for six years in a consulting role and
now in a c-level position at a german
retailer and on this channel i try to
pass on my knowledge and my experiences
with the hope that this is helpful and
valuable to you if you're taking any
value out of this video at all please
hit the like button for the youtube
algorithm and also please subscribe to
my channel to stay up to date on all my
content and also hit the notification
bell to make sure that you really see
every video that i bring out for those
of you who haven't seen it yet i
recently also started an instagram
channel where i post daily content daily
updates for you with little tips and
tricks what you can do to become
successful in the first years of your
career in today's video we're going to
talk about all things gmat as i scored
above 700 on my first sitting of the
exam i want to pass on four things for
you in this video first i want to give
you a bit of context i'm going to
explain to you why the gmat is so
important and why you need to do it well
in order to get access to the top
graduate business programs that you want
to study it second i'm going to share
some preparation advice what i did how i
studied for the gmat that enabled me
with only three weeks of preparation to
score above 700 in my first sitting of
the exam third i'm going to talk about
the economist gmat tutor online program
that i use to help me prepare for my
gmat and that i found insanely valuable
and then fourth i'm going to talk about
all the books that i bought these are
probably the most widely used the most
prevalent books on the gmail preparation
market and i'm going to give you my
brief and candid assessment which of
these books i found helpful and valuable
and which of these books i just found a
waste of time and money let's start by
briefly going over my personal gmat
learning story after i completed my
undergraduate degree in business from
the university of munich i wanted to
complete a finance master at the london
school of economics and i knew i needed
a gmat for that so i did lots of
research on the exam i purchased a
couple of books and then really studied
hard for three weeks it worked out well
for me i scored above 700 i was able to
get into the finance master program that
i wanted at the lse and after my master
program i started as consultant for
mckinsey and the berlin office and then
after a couple of years with mckinsey i
had the opportunity that mckinsey
offered to sponsor my mba at first i
wanted to redo the gmat for the mba
because i only studied for three weeks
and i saw that many people study for
much longer amounts of time and i felt
if i would just put in the time i would
be able to score an even higher result
so i started learning actually
purchasing a couple of other books which
is the main reason why the stack is now
so high but then after a couple of weeks
back into the preparation i decided for
myself that actually did not want to
take the exam again the main reason was
that at the moment i was working full
time for mckinsey i didn't have that
much time and i also talked to many
alumni of the inside mba program that i
wanted to get into and most of them told
me that the gmat reside that i have is
already completely fine because i scored
above 700. as the gmat was also valid
for five years i then decided to not do
it again to just take the result that i
have and in the end it was the right
decision because i got it so now that
that's out of the way let's jump in
let's jump into the first point what is
the gmat why it is so important gmat
stands for graduate management admission
test and it is an entry exam required by
pretty much all prestigious graduate
level business programs so both the
pre-experienced master programs but also
the post experience mba programs to get
admitted to them so this means that if
you want to get into one of the globally
leading business programs on a graduate
level you will need to take the gmat
exam and you will need a good score in
order to get admitted to the absolute
top programs so what is the exam
nowadays it consists of four parts first
the analytical writing assessment second
integrated reasoning third the quant
part and fourth the verbal part so let's
briefly go over these components let's
start with the first one the analytical
writing assessment in this section
you're required to write a short essay
to a specific question that you are
giving than in the exam the main reason
why this exists in the exam is that the
business schools want to make sure that
you actually wrote your essays your
application essays yourself if your
application essays are in flawless
english but you score really bad on this
analytical essay exercise then most
likely this means that you actually did
not write your essays yourself but you
probably had a ghostwriter what this
means for you is that this section of
the exam is pretty much only a hygiene
factor it is not too difficult to score
in the higher segments of this section
of the test and if your answer is just
above average this should usually be
fine for most schools here you want to
make sure that you are not raising any
red flags by having a score which is
really low especially if this is not
matched at all by the quality of your
other application assets integrated
reasoning is the second section of the
test here they have different types of
exercises where they show you charts
data diagrams and they just want to see
how when you're able to draw conclusions
from these things that are presented to
you this section was introduced through
the exam in 2012 it did not exist before
that and it is not part of the final
gmat score for these reasons it is not
that important this way just make sure
that you score above average here you do
not want to raise any red flags by
having an especially bad score but
usually if you score well in the quantum
the verbal part there should be no
reason why you shouldn't be able to also
score here high as well so make sure
that you familiarize yourself with the
types of questions that you're able to
score on a solid level but this is not
what will make or break your application
in the end especially if you have at
least an average or above average score
now to the two really important and
interesting parts and this is the quant
part and the verbal part as you can see
also time wise these two parts make the
majority of the test and from the scores
of these two sections your final gmat
score will be built the combined score
that can come out of the verbal in one
section will range between 200 and 800
so this is the range of scores that you
can get and this is the main score that
you will use for your business school
applications this is really the key
section where you want to score well
this is the section that you want to
prepare for this is the score that
matters this is what business schools
look out for so what scores do you
actually need in order to get admitted
to a top business school graduate level
program let's look into the statistics
of some mba programs because most people
will do the gmat foreign mba as per the
current financial times global mba
ranking the program that is at the
moment ranked number one is the harvard
business school mba program if you look
into the official latest class profile
of the harvard mba the median gmat score
is 730 so 730 out of 800 and the total
range deviates between 590 and 800. this
is pretty impressive because there are
only a couple of people worldwide to
actually achieve a perfect 800 score on
the gmat exam but this also shows you
that you can study at harvard business
school with a gmat of only 590 which is
indeed quite a low score for such a
leading mba program however what you
also need to recognize is that if you
look outside of the us programs the more
local programs tend to have gmat
averages which are significantly lower
just as an example let's look into the
best german mba program it's on rank 64
on the current financial times ranking
it is the whu mba program they do not
disclose the exact average in the class
so they talk about that from their
perspective most mba schools require
gmat score above 600 to get admitted and
just from a bit of desk research reading
online forums and so on i concluded that
the average of the whu is probably
around 650 so while this is not an
official number you can see that it is
significantly below the top mba programs
and it is much easier to get a score of
650 than to get a score above 700. so
how difficult is it really to score
higher on the gmat what i have prepared
for you here is a percentile table where
you can see in what percentile you fall
depending on the total score that you
achieve the percentiles change a bit
year on year but the mean score is 545
on the gmat if you want to belong to the
top 20 of the gmat test takers you will
need a score of at least
660. the score that most people try to
go for in the score that most people try
to consider really competitive for the
best programs is 700 and what you can
see here is the 700 roughly corresponds
to the top 10 of gmat test takers and if
you want to be part of the top 1 of gmat
test takers you need to score
760 or above of course you need to be
aware that those people who take the
gmat usually have completed at least one
undergraduate university degree they're
applying for a master or an mba degree
which shows they have some level of
ambition so it might be more difficult
than in other groups to score within the
top ten percent of test takers let's
start with some overall gmat test prep
advice what did i do to score away with
three weeks of preparation the first
thing that really worked well for me is
that i make sure that the time i prepare
for the gmat is really blocked by that i
didn't want to be distracted by any
other activities i didn't want to go to
university or go to a job and then only
in the evening be able to work on my
gmat i blocked three weeks and really
dedicated myself to gmat preparation
full time this way i put my full
attention on the gmat preparation every
single day of the three weeks and this
meant that i learned usually more than
six hours each of these days of course i
could have gone even longer but at some
point your brain just isn't able to
process the material anymore at least
mine isn't i had several friends at the
time who didn't want to do that they
continued to go to university or to
their job and then only learn for the
gmat maybe at the evening or at the
weekends if you do this and are still
able to score well you have my highest
respect but what just i have observed
for myself is just so much more
difficult if after a long work you
worked already many hours then in the
evening you want to concentrate yourself
again and try to learn try to get into
the material this is just so challenging
if you're somehow able really block
yourself the time for a couple of weeks
and then you will be much better off my
second insight is that when you learn
for the gmat the pareto principle or the
80 20 rule really holds true after a
couple of weeks of preparation you very
quickly reach a certain plateau and if
you reach that and then you want to
further improve the time that you need
to improve further will just go up
exponentially and at some point you just
need to ask yourself whether the time
invest is worth it or not for me
probably that point came after two weeks
after two weeks i started to realize
that my progress really slowed down
significantly and my strategy was that
already had the gmat test date after
week three of my preparation and if i
would not have achieved the test result
that i wanted i would probably have
rescheduled to another test date in the
future because as you might know you are
able to directly cancel your gmat test
results in a few minutes after you
complete the test the next key piece of
preparation advice is that you should
really do mock tests and the one that i
like best that i felt like resembled
most the actual test in the end was the
manhattan mock test you can either buy
exit to it on their website actually if
you get some of their books and i will
recommend you later some of them the
test access is already included with
them there are others as well i just
felt that the manhattan prep exam really
closely resembles the real thing in the
end so how exactly did i do it so after
two or three days of studying so after i
got the basic concept of what the gmat
was all about i decided to take the very
first mock exam to set a baseline for
myself so to understand from where i'm
starting and i remember that after these
two or three days i scored slightly
above 600 so it was a 6 10 or 6 20 or
something like that and from then on one
time per week and sometimes even two
times per week i took a new version of
the mock exam to track my progress and
understand where i'm standing this
helped me to get a live feedback whether
i'm on the right path whether learning
the studying that i'm doing is really
helping me to advance my score and in
fact the last mock exam that i took
roughly half a week before i took the
actual exam i scored to 710 which was
absolutely in the range of the final
result than i got in the real test the
next preparation advice is that while i
was studying i studied on some actual
real gmat test prep paper so i'm not
sure if you know but on the actual gmat
exam the type of paper you can use to
make notes it's standardized and it's
not a normal piece of paper instead it's
foiled paper and you can buy a paper
that very closely resembles this foil
paper here i got a set that i bought
myself that i use and as you can see it
has a special glossy foiled surface so
of course it's not hugely different than
writing a normal paper but at least you
should be aware of that and i just
wanted that my preparation comes as
close as possible to the actual test
experience so i bought this prep set i
will leave your link below down in the
description and as you can see there's
still some notes from the time when i
really learned for the gmat myself so it
made me a bit sentimental when i
actually looked at this but whenever i
did mock exercises whenever i studied i
made a point of always trying to take
notes and to write on this actual gmat
paper and of course it's not only a
paper but it's also the pen you need a
special foil marker in order to write on
this paper you will given that at the
test center but i found it helpful to
have already written with it to have
already worked with it in advance so it
was no surprise to me at all and my last
little prep advice is that even though
it's hard work and it's very serious for
all of us to get this test right still
try to see the fun of it and the use of
it beyond the exam itself so i found
that for me just preparing and studying
for the gmat exam that really helped
improve my quantitative skills so you
will take something out of it that will
go beyond the exam date itself there's a
use beyond the actual gmat test the next
thing i want to talk about is the
economist gmat tutor this is a program
that i found insanely helpful and
valuable when studying for my gmat exam
at the core of it you have an online
program that teaches you all the
strategies all the tips you need to
improve for the gmat and it also
includes lots and lots of mock exercises
besides that also included are some
private one-on-one video chat tutor
sessions with some experienced gmat
instructors you can submit essays that
they will rate and one of the best
things i thought is that they have a
score improvement guarantee of 50 to 70
points depending on which program you
take and 50 points are just huge 50
points are an absolute make or break of
your gmat exam so if you already took
the exam and want to improve your score
they guarantee you that with your
program you can improve by this amount
of points and if you don't you get your
money back and if you're a first-time
exam taker they will do a base exam at
the beginning to get your baseline and
then we'll guarantee to you that they
will improve you at least by that number
of points and if you don't you get your
money back and i have to admit it's
quite pricey it's quite an expensive
program but this way i really
rationalized it for me that if i do not
get the result that i want i would just
get my money back and hey for me it
worked really well so if you want to
check this out as well i have a link to
this course below in the video
description and the best thing is that
if you sign up via the link you can get
a seven day free trial and in these
seven days you can check out all the
functions by yourself for free so you
can really get a good feel whether this
is something that works for you and that
adds value for you so let's do some
brief and candid reviews of the books
and other materials i used to prepare
for my gmat exam i really hope that this
helps you get an understanding whether
it might be worth your time and your
investment let's start with the official
gmac books so these are the official
gmat books there's an overall guide and
then there are two more books one for
the quantitative section and then one
for the verb section so these are as i
told you the two main most important
sections of the test these books have
lots of practice exams and this is why i
believe they're great so if you really
want to get a whole bunch of exams that
you want to go through and work with and
this really helps and the other pluses
of course these are the official books
and the main reason for me why i bought
them is that i just didn't want to miss
out on any of the official information
that the gmat test takers themselves
have put out there so i'd say that these
books were helpful and great if you want
to do lots of practices but they were a
bit lacking on the really difficult
upper level types of questions so my
opinion is that i would recommend you to
get them these are the official books
after all and if you sign up for the
gmat usually there's also an option to
then get these books a bit cheaper so it
should be quite a good deal as well
there are lots of great practice exams
in it just be sure that you also get
some additional material because
otherwise you might struggle with the
more difficult gmat questions let's now
look into some of the books of kaplan
kaplan is a pretty well known and famous
gmat test prep provider as well at the
time i bought two books from kaplan one
was the kaplan gmat premiere book i
believe right now they discontinued the
book and we packaged it into some of the
other material and frankly i did not
really like this book and the main
reason was that i felt that the material
in here is far too easy the book claims
that this book has quote
everything you need to score higher and
it also claims higher score guaranteed
and i can just tell you that this book
was extremely basic the strategies and
exercises covered did not even come
close to help you really ace the higher
more difficult questions in the exam so
even though this book is discontinued at
the moment for this experience i would
be a bit careful with the kaplan
material especially the more basic ones
at least this book really surprised me
in a negative way so really make sure
you know what you're buying if you're
getting into the kaplan material however
there's also positive thing i want to
mention about kaplan and this is this
book the gmat 800 book and this is a
book that still exists today and this is
now the kaplan book that really focuses
on the more difficult advanced students
and their claim is advanced prep for
advanced students master the questions
that most people get wrong and yes i
really liked this one this one does
cover some great and advanced strategies
and this one really helped me to get to
the higher levels to solve the more
difficult problems in the gmat the books
that i can recommend you most to prepare
for your gmat based on the material that
i used is the manhattan gmat strategy
guide series it's a series of 10 or so
books and these books are really great
because they both teach you some great
and also advanced strategies on how you
should tackle the different types of
questions that you're facing with the
gmat and they also have lots of practice
exams so they have books on all kinds of
topics they have books on fractions
decimals and presents on algebra and
word problems geography number
properties sentence correction
integrated reasoning on the essay part
and so on so this is really all the
stuff that you need in order to get your
gmat right and the great additional
bonus is that if you buy the set as it
also says here it includes six free
online exams from manhattan so this is
the mock exam that i recommended to you
earlier i felt that from all the mock
exams that i looked into the manhattan
mock exam was the one that most closely
resembled the real thing in the end and
also the results that i got in the ides
core were really closely matching the
actual result that i got in my real gmat
test and if you look into the
description down below you can find a
link to this book series and also the
other books that i recommended in my
description so have a look check it out
if this might be interesting to you
finally i want to discuss another
manhattan book and this was the
manhattan advanced quant preparation
book and from the series there are some
other books as well and in this series
there are some other books for manhattan
as well really deep diving on individual
elements of the gmat test i found that
yes this was helpful and if there are
some areas where you really struggle
with and if you have enough time that
you've went through all the other
material then yes this might be helpful
but personally i found that this was
probably just too much i didn't really
need that if you have all the other
stuff that's already enough but if there
are some areas where you really struggle
and want some additional insight some
additional tips and tricks then yes
these advanced books on the specific
topics might be helpful and interesting
as well i hope this video helped you
understand how i scored above 700 in my
gmat exam with only three weeks of
preparation and i hope that this helped
inspired and motivated you to also get
your gmat test prep right and also help
you achieve a high result i would of
course love to hear about your gmat test
prep experience do you agree with the
tips that i have did you do something
else what are your top tips to ace the
gmat let me know in the comments below
i'll answer every single comment that
you write so i'd love to have a
discussion with you here on this channel
and if you took any value out of this
video at all please smash the like
button for the youtube algorithm and
also subscribe to this channel to stay
up to date on all the content that i'm
releasing i will bring out at least one
video every single saturday for you if
you want to get even more content from
me follow my instagram under firm
learning on my instagram i'm releasing
daily pieces of content for you on how
to be successful in the first years of
your career thank you for watching this
was heine from firm learning stay safe
and to the next time